if 14th century europe was a tapestry
it was woven together by ships and by
boats
by sea routes and by river routes
ironically it was these very same
interconnected routes which would prove
to be the path by which plague would
spread across the continent
maritime and river trade brought
devastating plague to england and the
great realms of the iberian peninsula
castile aragon portugal
and granada
and yet across much of western europe it
also facilitated a dramatic economic
rebound in the generations after the
plague
a rebound so dramatic that some
historians have questioned whether the
plague could have been so terrible after
all
it was in fact every bit as terrible
indeed worse than traditionally believed
but its seas and its rivers would bring
a remarkable recovery
one of the great european river routes
was the guadalcabir river
which runs through cordoba and seville
in southern spain
in the late middle ages the guadalquivir
was more navigable than it is today
it's been silted up over the centuries
we have a vivid description of the river
traffic of seville from the century
before the black death written by the
great learned king of castile alfonso
the wise
there is no such well-situated and
harmonious city in the world alfonso
wrote
a city to which a ship comes by river
every day
for ships and galleys and other sea
going vessels bring even within the city
walls all the merchandise of the world
from tangier tunis the jaya alexandria
genoa portugal england and the list goes
on
its olive oil alone supplies the whole
world
as this description suggests in passing
england itself crisscrossed by navigable
rivers and blessed with an extremely
long indented coastline
was also fully integrated into
international maritime trade
england was not yet britannia and its
ship masters did not yet rule the seas
but they battled with them and for
control of them
they sailed up river to london and to
inland ports like gloucester on the
river seven
which was also more navigable than today
and they endlessly plied the rough
waters of the atlantic the north sea and
the baltic
port cities like gloucester southampton
weymouth and bristol were thriving on
the eve of the black death
in the canterbury tales of the taberdin
and southwark
geoffrey chaucer the pilgrim runs into
one of these shipmasters
the shipment says chaucer came from the
little port city of dartmouth in the
west country
he's evidently a tough weather beaten
man
he's not above pilfering some of the red
wine he ships in from bordeaux
and when he faces down his enemies
chaucer says he's been known to send
some of them overboard into the water
but he's a skilled mariner too
he knows how to calculate the tides and
the currents
he knows all the havens and harbours
from gotland to cape venesto
this was valuable knowledge in the
stormy atlantic
ships sailing from england would have
rounded finisterre on the rocky coast of
galicia
on their way to lisbon and beyond to
seville
english ships like the shipments boats
had just begun sailing again to seville
at the time the choice was right in the
canterbury tales
after years of military conflict in
spain
finisterre the westernmost tip of spain
is located on the so-called costa
damorte the coast of death
where oil tankers and freight ships
still run aground in the 21st century
shipping after all brings both danger
and opportunity
ships brought death in the mid 14th
century but they would also enable
economic resilience and recovery in
western europe after the plague
in england it was in the tiny port of
malcolm near weymouth that the plague
first arrived
in 1348 a franciscan chronicler tells us
two ships landed at malcolm in dorset a
little bit before mid-summer
in them were sailors from bordeaux who
were infected with an unheard-of
pestilence
another account adds that it then killed
innumerable people
next it came to bristol where very few
were left alive
the plague we read traveled northwards
leaving not a city a town a village or
even a house
so that over england as a whole a fifth
of the men women and children were
carried to burial
how high in fact was plagued mortality
as it swept into europe
this figure of one-fifth is very much on
the low side i think most historians
agree that even the traditional figure
of one-third which used to appear in all
the textbooks is probably an
underestimate
at the other end of the scale several
english chroniclers state that scarcely
a tenth of mankind was left alive
implying 90 mortality
this i think is a stock phrase
expressing trauma and shock without
being statistically reliable
some european chroniclers may have
exaggerated the impacts
the writer giovanni boccaccio claimed
it is reliably thought that over 100 000
human lives were extinguished within the
walls of the city of florence
but this figure probably exceeds the
total population of the city at this
time
recent calculations suggest that an
accurate estimate of the overall
mortality rate
would be at least 40 percent in the
first great wave of plague in 1348 to 51
with 50 and above in some specific areas
including florence
the disease then became endemic in the
population
later outbreaks like those which
occurred in 1361 and 62 and 1368 often
killed upwards of 5 to 10 percent of the
population
although the plague then disappeared
from western europe in the early 18th
century
it would continue to menace the south
and east of the continent
it devastated north africa and both the
russian and ottoman empires into the
19th century and beyond
in fact according to the historian nuked
valik
the last record of plague in the
territories that fell within the ottoman
empire occurred as late as 1947
on the border of turkey and syria
this would suggest that the plague
survived a full 600 years in that part
of the world
the original spread of the plague in
europe in the mid-14th century is
usually depicted as a sequence of
expanding lines washing slowly across
the continent in orderly waves between
1347 and 51
but it was probably diffused in a more
complex way
it makes better sense i think to imagine
arrows of infection shooting outwards
almost simultaneously from a variety of
ports on the black sea the mediterranean
the atlantic the north sea and the
baltic
from these coastal ports the disease was
then born inland by a variety of vectors
rodents animal fleas human fleas human
beings and perhaps birds
it was then diffused from other major
urban centers like florence where
giovanni picaccio composed his decameron
it was picacho who left us the single
most famous description of the disease
although what he describes is merely the
best known form of the disease bubonic
plague
whose most horrific symptoms are the
glandular swellings or buboes
in the early spring of 1348 boccaccio
writes
the plague began in a terrifying and
extraordinary manner to make its
disastrous effects apparent
its earliest symptom in men and women
alike was the appearance of certain
swellings in the groin or the armpits
some of which were egg-shaped while
others were roughly the size of the
common apple
later boccaccio added people began to
find dark blotches and bruises on their
arms their thighs and other parts of the
body
these he concluded
were an inevitable portent of death
it's almost impossible to overstate the
magnitude of the horror that europeans
experienced in these first few years
their suffering their trauma and their
grief
for many observers it must certainly
have seemed that the survival of our
species was in danger
this was the darkest hour in the history
of medieval europe
but always there was someone to kindle
the flickering lights
the irish monk john clin was among them
i
seeing these many ills
and that the whole world is encompassed
by evil
waiting among the dead for death to come
have committed to writing what i have
truly heard and examined he wrote
and so that the writing does not perish
with the writer or the work fail with
the workman
i leave parchment for continuing the
work in case anyone should still be
alive in the future
it is the depth of despair that makes
their resilience so extraordinary
new generations would soon be picking up
the parchment and reassembling the
pieces of their shattered worlds
instead of rehearsing the catalogue of
horrors which afflicted the continent
it may be worth flipping the coin and
asking was anywhere in europe spared
from the plague
let's take a look at a few regions that
have been proposed as candidates
some historians have suggested that the
far north of europe benefiting from
relative isolation and colder climatic
conditions
may have been hit less hard than the
highly networked commercial centers of
the mediterranean
there may be some truth to this
cold temperatures in the north of
scotland
may have limited the spread of plague
they may only have been warm enough to
support a rat population during the
summer months
at first the scots sensed an advantage
one chronicler relates that hearing of
the cruel plague among the english they
glimpsed an opportunity
to invade their hated old enemy south of
the border
however this did not last long
as they gathered near the border to
prepare an invasion
a fierce mortality came upon them we
read and the sudden cruelty of a
monstrous death winnowed the scots
the plague also decimated scandinavia an
english ship docked at the keysight in
bergen norway in 1349
disease spread from the crew to the
town's people as the cargo was unloaded
and two-thirds of the people died
in a charter from the autumn of 1349 the
king of norway and sweden magnus eriksen
gave instructions about measures to be
taken in the face of the great mortality
as it reached norway and southern sweden
he alludes to the death of half the
population
king magnus wrote to the pope in 1350
excusing the inability of his kingdom to
participate in the crusades against
russia because of the devastating impact
of the disease
wills from this period also make dark
allusions to the difficulties of the
times
among the northern european countries in
fact only distant iceland was spared due
to its
isolation even iceland would be
devastated by two appalling epidemics
100 years later despite the absence of
rats
the absence suggests that mnemonic
transmission from human to human was at
work
it's often said that bohemia in what is
now the modern czech republic was able
to escape the plague
the chronicler francis of prague
suggested that the black death having
caused massive suffering in neighboring
austria
had miraculously spared bohemia in 1348
it's certainly possible that bohemia and
some german cities which were far
removed from maritime routes places like
frankfurt dusseldorf and berlin were
indeed hit less hard than the average
much less hard perhaps than italian
cities like florence
but this same chronicler acknowledges
that the disease also struck in bohemia
a couple of years later in 1350 in short
nowhere on the european continent was
saved
let's now return to the place where we
started in spain
it used to be argued that perhaps
because of its relatively dry climate
spain was less hard hit than other parts
of western europe
let's zoom into this region in more
detail asking how the various christian
kingdoms here castile navarre and aragon
along with the neighboring realm of
portugal were impacted
and how they were able to recover
in the spring of
1348 two real-life pilgrims set off from
portugal
heading from the holy shrine of saint
francis of assisi
a journey they hoped to complete by the
autumn of that year
but as they walked east crossing the
plains of castile and entering the
kingdom of aragon the mood gradually
darkened
as news of plague began to spread
the pilgrims found themselves the
targets of suspicion like other
outsiders and ethnic minorities
across europe marginal groups of people
including jews and foreigners
were widely accused of responsibility
for the disease and of having poisoned
the water supplies
many faced verbal and physical abuse
homicide and in the case of the jews
genocide
by mid-summer the pilgrims were in fear
for their lives vulnerable to physical
aggression as well as to the lethal
bacteria
determined to make their way back home
in july 1348
they were given a safe conduct by the
king of aragon pedro the ceremonies
pedro had left valencia when the plague
reached the coast and his court was now
installed some way in land
at this moment the plague was spreading
throughout the entire iberian peninsula
ironically the movement of pilgrims and
royal courts just like the activities of
merchants and sailors accelerated this
diffusion
there were probably multiple
simultaneous points of entry into the
peninsula
we know the plague had arrived in the
northeast in the border counties of
catalonia by april 1348.
the king of aragon wrote to the governor
of the beautiful mediterranean islands
of majorca warning him of the danger
but by this stage it was already too
late
as early as february the governor of
majorca had already sent a letter
ordering officials to inspect all ships
coming from ports in the eastern
mediterranean
he knew what these ships could bring
but his efforts were unsuccessful
on may the 3rd the officials asked the
king to send armed galleys from
barcelona and valencia
because the plague had now struck so
badly that they couldn't defend
themselves against muslim pirates or the
powerful muslim king of tunisia
the plague had an appalling impact on
jewish communities in spain
both directly and because of the
religious violence that it provoked
it reached barcelona by mid-may 1348
sparking anti-semitic attacks in the
jewish quarter and in neighboring towns
five years later king pedro of aragon
ordered officials in the inland town of
larida
to provide a new cemetery for the jewish
community because the old one had been
filled with bodies of plague victims
high status in christian society offered
no protection from the disease either
the king of aragon wrote to his uncle
the count of a realm high up in the
pyrenees mountains
to express his condolences at the death
of the count's wife
the count's younger daughter would also
die soon afterwards
the king of aragon himself would survive
but his wife queen leonor would not
in late october he frantically summoned
four physicians from valencia because
leonor was ill
she passed away even before they arrived
from port cities and towns across the
peninsula the plague spread with
frightening speed
historians have often claimed that one
of the epicenters was santiago de
compostela the pilgrimage center to
which thousands of people traveled from
across europe in this period and indeed
today
but in fact the whole western coast the
coast which chaucer's shipment knew like
the back of his weather-beaten hands
was vulnerable
the same was true of the southeastern
coast in particular the city of almeria
one of the main ports of the muslim
kingdom of granada
a medical treatise by the muslim
physician and poet ibn khatimat
suggests that the plague had sunk its
teeth into al-maria by june 1348.
we don't know much yet about the death
rates in seville
the same dazzling city that alfonso the
wise had described in the passage with
which we began this lecture
but we can be sure that those ships
sailing in on the guadalcabia river
would have brought on board infection
and destruction
what exactly was the overall mortality
rate in spain
coastal regions were probably hit harder
than landlocked areas
but evidence from jewish graves suggests
that even places like toledo in the dead
center of the peninsula were afflicted
terribly
across the plains of castile there was a
major economic shift towards pastoral
farming which didn't require very much
manpower
and in particular the merino wool sector
for navarre a kingdom nestled in the
foothills of the pyrenees
which young geoffrey chaucer was to
visit one mid-winter about 20 years
later
some scholars have proposed a figure as
high as a 50 percent death rate
navarre was a common point of entry for
travellers and for merchants as well as
messengers riding across the mountains
to and from france or pilgrims riding
and walking to santiago
soldiers criss-crossed the high peaks to
participate in both theaters of fighting
in the hundred years war france and
spain
and helped spread disease with them as
they marched
the rate was equally high in catalonia
embedded in networks of mediterranean
trade
historians have pointed to a long-term
decline even a crisis in catalan
commerce in the late 14th and 15th
centuries
here as elsewhere in spain the impacts
of the first wave of plague was
exacerbated by later outbreaks
barcelona which may have had a
population of around 38 000 in the early
1380s
had only half of this number some 20 000
by the middle of the next century
there was a great shortage of laborers
across the region bringing higher wages
for some workers but trouble for others
up in the mountains financially squeezed
landlords began to impose harsher and
harsher conditions on their peasants
one revisionist spanish historian
has challenged this grim picture of the
plague in iberia
for him the impact of the black death
has been exaggerated spain was different
from the rest of western europe he says
but let's take a close look at the
evidence
this historian guillermo castan points
to what he sees as surprising silences
on the part of spanish and portuguese
chroniclers
there's no contemporary narrative that
reflects a sense of demographic
catastrophe he says
although some of these chroniclers do
specify that the plague was present
among the castilian forces besieging
gibraltar
and they reveal that alfonso the 11th of
castile died in 1350 as a result of the
disease while participating in this
siege
the problem is that arguing from silence
in our sources is always
dangerous
there are other texts that suggest a
perception at the time that the plague
was completely universal
in the summer of 1348 for example the
king of aragon rewarded his personal
physician for his services during the
height of the plague which he says had
infected almost the whole world
in a letter to the king of castile
alfonso the 11th in march 1350
shortly before alfonso himself died
he describes how because of the
mortality that by god's will has fallen
on spain and in the same way across the
entire world
all of spain is depopulated
a second dimension to the revisionist
argument
is that the epidemic of 1348 cannot have
been so terrible because it did not
interrupt military campaigning in spain
just as king alfonso the 11th carried on
besieging gibraltar the aragonese were
still able to pursue a policy of
military expansion
in the mid to late 1350s
the war with castile that ensued was to
last well over a decade
but this is again slippery evidence if
we look at the broader european picture
no one doubts that florence for example
was absolutely decimated by the plague
and yet even in 1349-50
while the first wave of disease was
still devastating the city the
florentine authorities also began a new
war against a powerful aristocratic
family
and in 1351 they became involved in a
conflict with the rival states of milan
nowhere was plague an obstacle to war
for very long
the fact that military campaigning
continued is not necessarily a sign that
the plague had only a limited effect
one final factor that's invoked as an
argument that spain cannot have been
that badly affected
is the economic vitality of many parts
of the peninsula in the late 14th
century
in the basque country in northern spain
the appearance of new towns suggests
that this was in fact a period of growth
bilbao emerged as an important export
center
in galicia in the northwest urban life
flourished in the decades after the
black death this was a very prosperous
period for galician port cities like
acoruna
and further south on the atlantic coast
the portuguese city of lisbon was also
thriving
english ships and merchants received
special trade privileges in lisbon in
1367.
chaucer's fictional shipment and his
real-life counterparts would have known
all of these places very well indeed
but economic vitality does not mean that
the black death had avoided spain and
portugal any more than it had avoided
england
we know from our own experience that
pandemic disease may strike at different
times and with different intensities in
the short term
but that in the longer run the impact is
as the king of aragon believed almost
universal
instead what we're seeing is economic
resilience
in the practical world of trade commerce
and sailing the survivors were
rebuilding their worlds
and they were soon to discover new ones
from the little port of dartmouth and
bigger cities like southampton and
london
english shipment was soon plying the
rough seas of the bay of biscay once
again
within a century the coasts of portugal
would become the point of departure for
the earliest global european empire
portuguese mariners navigated their way
down the west african coast
often acting in conjunction with
merchants from venice genoa and florence
bringing back gold cloth and slaves
they sailed into the indian ocean too
where they latched on to vast
pre-existing networks of trade
lisbon was destined to become a great
multi-racial center of colonial trade
and exploitation
the success of these portuguese ventures
would galvanize christopher columbus to
set sail in 1492
from the little spanish ports of palos
de la frontera
initiating a sequence of voyages that
would transport culture and disease
west and east across the atlantic
and seville
the muslim city on the guadalcana river
which had mesmerized alfonso the wise
would become by the 16th century the
greatest commercial metropolis in the
whole of europe
the benefits of this new wealth would be
unevenly shared
there would be poverty as well as
prosperity
but the rebound from the plague which
remained endemic in spain and in europe
was nothing short of astonishing